do you trust your bank to be honest I
don't really think I trust my bank it's
really uncertain if one day they can
like close our accounts what do you
think about the fact that it's easier
get a bank loan to go on holiday or to
get married than it is to invest in a
property yeah that's that's that's
pretty bad did you know that the bank
uses your savings for their Investments
and what do you think about that I
didn't I didn't know that and I think
it's a bit it's a bit sneaky so you put
money in the bank keep it safe they
invest it think is sneaky I I don't if I
don't know then I should know it's my
money right they've got hidden agendas
clearly I guess